on the next episode of AMC's The Walking
Dead
you don't scare easy
I love theirs hey youtubers is Charlie
so new Walking Dead we're gonna learn a
little bit more about the culture of the
Savior's negan's wives although his one
true love really is Lucille for any of
you that thought that Episode two was
kind of slow because it was a Carol
episode this is where they crank it back
up and there is a bunch of comic book
stuff happening I mean really like any
episode with negan in it is gonna be a
comic book episode because they're doing
so much comic book stuff this year but
what it looks like is happening is
they've swapped Eugene in the comics who
gets captured by the Savior's for Daryl
so Daryl is kind of like comic book
Eugene in these moments so they
basically throw them in a prison that
looks kind of like this where they're
walking Daryl around you see a little
bit of the Savior's culture how like
they are very dangerously organized like
everybody's been teasing but it's almost
like they have a pirate culture where
they just spend their entire time
fighting with each other even though
they have their own culture it flows a
lot from Meegan's idea you know your
stuff belongs to me I'm just gonna take
what I want
and then we see even more comic book
stuff happening when we meet sherry
again if you don't remember sherry
she's Dwight's wife we met her way back
when they stole Darrell's bike like at
the beginning of this Darryl vs. Dwight
feud so I think that's one of the
reasons why they swapped Darryl for a
comic book Eugene just because it feels
a little more personal he has history
with these two people so if you've read
the comics you know exactly what she
means when she says you know whatever
he's done there's more meaning that it's
gonna get way WAY worse if you think the
stuff that negan has done is terrible
he's done way more stuff that you just
haven't seen yet so they're gonna reveal
some of that in this episode so I don't
know that I would call Shari like a huge
comic book character but she does have a
big comic book arc and they'll be doing
some of that in this so even if you
don't sympathize with her and Dwight
because of all the stuff they've done to
Daryl you'll at least understand a
little bit about how they're fighting
for their lives too and doing whatever
they can to survive in how terrible
things are for them
in the saviour's the things you have to
do in order to live with the savior
sometimes are worse than being their
enemies so we'll learn a little bit
about that through Sherry's character
like especially if you're a woman a
beautiful woman inside the Savior's it
can be really bad for you so I will just
tease negan harem and you guys can let
me know in the comments like what you're
most hyped up about because the Savior's
are terrible but the stuff that negan
does to the Savior's is almost as bad as
the stuff that negan did to the
survivors last week comic book Sheree
didn't really show up to like issue 105
which was well after negan made his
debut and killed Glenn so you can kind
of see how they've changed the comic
book plot a little bit just to give them
a little bit more backstory with
Darryl's character in fact maybe they
always knew that they were gonna do this
thing with Daryl send him to the Savior
so it would resonate more when they were
doing this comic book Dwight Sharri
negan stuff but if you thought that
Dwight was an interesting character like
it especially if you're a comic book
person you're like oh I'll get all this
Dwight stuffs going on then Sheree has
the potential to be a really really
interesting character too but it depends
on how much stuff they do from her comic
book story so you have to remember that
there's like a whole bunch of comic book
characters that don't make it onto the
TV show so they tend to speed through
comic book plot quite a bit so what they
might do is they might just like
condense a lot of Cherie stuff and give
you the broad strokes like we might not
see the full negan harem but you guys
can let me know like how much comic book
stuff from the Saviour storyline you
think they'll do but typically they
always do like the biggest moment so if
there's something that's like really
crazy they'll at least tease it even if
they don't do it in excruciating detail
but there's like this whole different
dynamic in the Savior's group like it
gets super crazy so I feel like they'll
be one of the most interesting comic
book groups on the TV show even though
Ezekiel and Shiva seem really cool I
feel like negan and the Savior's will be
more interesting characters to watch
just because there's so much crazier and
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner
Norsemen bolts you win a $20 Amazon gift
card be sure to private message be on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details so whole bunch of
Marvel DC comic book stuff happening
this week there actually is some
specific stuff that I want to do so I'll
try to fit that in whenever I can
there's some really cool infamous
Ironman Doctor Doom stuff that's
happening in the comics so I want to do
video for that pretty soon well you guys
wait for that to post you can click down
here for last night's episode to video
and you can click here for my
non-spoilery Doctor Strange review thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight